We just demonstrated some powerful LLDB
commands and each of the commands is now
another tool that you can use when
your paused at a break point.
I hope you're beginning to see a pattern
in how we can use break points and
tools together.
That is, that we can set breakpoints,
and then we can get our apps
to reach break points, and
then we can use tools to examine our
applications while they're paused.
But there are also some other
interesting ways that we can
edit the very nature of a breakpoint so
that it doesn't necessarily
pause an application.
For example,
we can modify breakpoints so that they
only pause in certain circumstances,
like only pause after the 10th bug is
created, instead of just the first bug.
Or we can make breakpoints that
don't pause the applications at all,
instead they can perform
some behavior and
then just let the application
continue running.
For instance, don't pause, play a sound.
To achieve these kinds of behaviors,
we'll use breakpoint actions, and
specifically that's what
breakpoint actions are,
they're behaviors that are triggered
when a breakpoint is reached.
So to demonstrate, I'm going to start
in the breakpoint navigator and
right now we have no breakpoints.
I've removed the ones that we had, but
let's add one for the add bug to view.
There we go, so now it shows up.
And if we right click a breakpoint,
then a context menu pops up and
we can select this option
to edit the breakpoint.
And here's where the fun happens.
But before we add and
action or a breakpoint action,
let's work with the other fields first.
So we see this condition field at
the top and this allows up to specify
a condition that must be true in
order for a breakpoint to be active.
For this breakpoint let's specify
that the count of the bug's array
must be greater than three before
the breakpoint is triggered.
And to do this,
I'll type in the expression
bugs.count is greater than three,
and we'll hit enter.
And let's go ahead and
run the application.
And stopped.
If we look down in bugs, we can
see that we have four image views.
So the bugs are greater than three and
our breakpoint has now been triggered.
So let's stop this and go back and
edit our breakpoint again.
And I'll clear the condition and
this time let's set the ignore
times before stopping value.
We'll make it two and rerun the app,
tap the screen, and there we go.
It ignored it the first two times,
and created two bugs, and now
we're on the third iteration through,
and about to create our third bug.
Let's stop this one more time.
Go back to the breakpoint navigator and
edit again.
So we'll make sure this is zero and
this time let's select this check box
that says, automatically continue
after evaluating actions.
I'll run this again and when we click,
it appears that the break
point has been skipped.
However, that's not exactly the case.
It only looks like
the breakpoint's being skipped.
What's happening, is because there
are no break point actions specified,
the breakpoint was triggered, but
then immediately evaluated
zero actions and continued.
So if we add an action,
we can prove that something
else should have happened.
So we'll click edit and
the first action type that we'll look
at is the debug or command action.
This includes a text field for entering
any valid commands that we could use
at the LLDB command line interface.
So we'll do our PO command we saw
earlier, print out bugs, then run.
Then we can see that it's evaluating,
it's evaluating a lot because we're
creating a lot of bugs, but then it
should just fall through our breakpoint,
it has never paused our application.
It is taking more time to
actually execute though
because it has to run the actions.
So we can really see our problem now
because with one tap way more than
one bug was being created, and
we kept seeing the contents of
this update over and over again.
So let's stop and see if we can
see this problem another way.
So go back and edit.
And this time we're going to
add a new breakpoint action, so
we click the plus and
let's choose sound and
we'll keep it this default
bottle sound and run again.
Let me turn on,
make sure we can hear this.
[SOUND] And now,
we can hear the problem too.
So each time a bug was added to the
view, the breakpoint was triggered and
our sound played.
And you can actually even add your
custom sounds instead of the default
ones, and I've included a link in the
instructor notes if you're interested.
So let's stop this one more time and
talk about the remaining actions
that we haven't looked at yet.
I'm not going to show examples for
each of the actions because some of them
are outside the scope of this class but
there are additional
resources in the instructor notes that
can guide you through using them.
So in the breakpoint editor, which we
see here, we'll add one more action.
And here at the top, we see AppleScript.
And what an AppleScript action is
going to allow you to do is run
an AppleScript's script
when the breakpoint is hit.
The next one is capture a GPU frame,
and this does exactly what it says,
and it can be useful if you're
debugging applications using OpenGL or
something like that, using SpriteKit.
Then we have the log message, which will
either log a message to the console,
or we can actually speak it back to us
but I'll admit that having the computer
speak back to you can feel
a little bit like Space Odyssey.
And then the last action
is the Shell command.
And similar to the AppleScript action,
this allows you to run a shell script
when the breakpoint is reached.
One way this can be really useful is for
an app that might need
to clear the local database records each
time the app is run in the simulator.
So instead of doing this manually,
you can set a breakpoint and
actually run a script that clears
the local database for you.
And really, there are endless
possibilities with what you could do
with this, so I'd encourage you to
experiment with them in your own
projects, and if you like, there's
another cool thing we can do here.
We can actually share
our breakpoints too.
So if you right click any
breakpoint in the navigator and
you select share breakpoint,
then it'll now show up as shared, and
the breakpoint will be included as
part of your Xcode project file.
And this means that you can share your
Xcode project with anyone else, and they
should see the breakpoint, and because
the shared breakpoint is recorded
as part of a file, then it'll also show
up in version control systems like Git.